hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
simplify and prove your answer to the
following expression you're not allowed
to use calculators or computers
i received many email requests for this
type of problem i think akshat in india
for suggesting it to me first
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so how can we simplify this expression
i'll first write a as the number that's
under the first cube root and then b
will be a square root conjugate that's
under the second cube root
notice that the cube root of a is a real
number and the cube root of b is a real
number so their sum will also be a real
number so in the end we're looking for a
real number
now we'll set this entire expression
which is the cube root of a plus the
cube root of b
we'll set that equal to x
now we'll cube both sides
and then we'll expand
now let's simplify this expression
we'll first put the squares inside of
these cube roots
now we'll group these cube roots
together
we can then write a squared as a a and b
squared as bb
notice we have an a b term here and a ba
term here and they'll be equal to each
other
what's the product of square root
conjugates
the nice thing is it will be a
difference of squares and this
simplifies to be negative five cubed
we'll substitute that in
and now
negative 5 cubed if we take the cube
root of that we end up with negative 5.
3 times negative 5 is equal to negative
15.
so we then have negative 15 and we can
group the remaining terms which will be
the cube root of a plus the cube root of
b
we now recall that x was defined to be
exactly this quantity so we can
substitute that in
now a plus b
will be equal to just 16 because the
square root terms will cancel
so we end up with a simple polynomial
expression
x cubed is equal to 16 minus 15x
if there's a solution in this equation
we're looking for a real value to be the
answer to our original expression
so we write x cubed plus 15x minus 16 is
equal to 0.
how can we solve this equation
well usually you can try special values
and you'll quickly see that x is equal
to 1 is a solution to this equation
consequently x minus 1 will be a factor
of this polynomial
so we can factor this into the following
product of x minus 1 and the quadratic x
squared plus x plus 16.
we can solve the quadratic using the
quadratic formula
but we'll learn that the quadratic roots
both involve non-zero imaginary parts so
they're extraneous roots they can't be
the answer to our original problem
because we're looking for a real value
of x
this means the answer is x is equal to
one
wow this is a most unexpected answer for
a simple algebra problem
now you might double check this exercise
by typing it in wolfram alpha
will it give the answer of one
you might surprisingly find that it
gives a complex answer with a non-zero
imaginary part
what's going on
well wolfram alpha is using the
principal root
the reason is the equation x cubed
equals c has three solutions
and wolfram alpha will take the
principal branch cut which is most
commonly used in higher mathematics
but we don't want the principal branch
cut we want the real valued root so how
can we force wolfram alpha to do that
there are a couple of ways
one is you can use the command of cube
root that in fact will give you the real
valued root and you will get the answer
one
and for other roots you can use the
command absurd of x comma n this will
give you the real nth root of x
it's a pretty neat problem
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world they have over 100
million views and the channel has over 1
million subscribers please subscribe for
free to get the newest videos you can
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise on
teespring you can check out my books
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support